president biden desperately wants you to
think his sputtering economy is doing
well the president rolling out a plan to
spin sky-high inflation and gas prices
that keep setting new records biden
holding a rare oval office meeting this
afternoon with fed chairman jerome
powell and biden sharing his plan to
fight inflation in wall street journal
op-ed
biden's goal appears to be to convince
upset boaters that things aren't that
bad and try to pass the inflation blame
on to republicans the president claims
to know what he is doing but one of his
top advisors is refusing to answer
simple questions
give us a forecast where can you have
gas prices let's let's say by the end of
the year where will they be
this is a serious issue
and what you're doing right now is
trying to put me in the position of
being a forecaster what is your ability
to control those prices and bring them
down
what you want from your president is
that they're doing everything they can
curious sandra i must tell you that i
watch that back and forth he refused to
give you an answer he couldn't give you
an answer what was your take on it i
felt those were really fair
questions not simple um solutions
certainly not but he didn't offer
specific answers what they're doing to
bring these prices down i i had very
specific questions about whether why
they're touting uh this economy as as in
some position of strength when people
are paying record high gas prices 4.62
cents is the new record high today
inflation is at a 40-year high in this
country and i also asked him is this
white house merely reacting
to what is happening with the american
economy are they trying to get ahead of
things getting even worse from here
you've had larry summers steve ratner
all economists inside democratic
administrations who have been raising
the flag the red flag on what is
happening with this economy for quite
some time and there's nowhere to run and
hide now the washington post literally
just published this piece
on the misjudgment of this white house
of the inflation threat until it was too
late and it goes date by date which the
biden administration was playing down
playing down the economic consequences
of their policies uh going back to july
19th you remember all the talk about the
inflation being transitory and then it
was then it was shifting the blames to
the companies right that it was shifting
the blame to vladimir putin invading
ukraine um so i was just trying to hold
the white house accountable we gave them
a lot of time to explain their their
plan and unfortunately we didn't really
get it all right jessie uh you know
sandra i saw it she she said well you
said inflation was transitory i mean why
can't you give us an idea actually they
even met today with powell as inflation
is dogging the economy and they keep
insisting that the economy is better
than we think it is like don't believe
your lying eyes yeah
the economy's great
wake up surf i mean 75 percent of the
country says the country is an
absolute you know what hole
and biden's telling the people that are
struggling you don't know how good you
have it he says he's pivoting to the
economy what else has he been working on
god and then he says you know what all
the bad things about the economy none of
it's my fault it's someone else's fault
it's the fed chair's fault who missed
inflation but biden just reappointed the
fed chair and he says it's congress's
fault too but the democrats controlled
congress and then he says it's putin's
fault but this gas price thing was going
up way before he invaded and he invaded
on his watch and then he says this he
goes you know what my solution spend
more money i mean any idiot knows that's
a really dumb idea he's got a lot of
political problems black americans
they're upset in the white house they're
very angry and a lot of the black voters
say what have you done for me lately we
put you in there and you haven't
delivered same with the far left the far
left put him in there he hasn't
delivered on the green new dealio or
anything like that and all of his donors
are angry too and i saw polls that come
out say is it 35 in delaware his home
state hates him he's at 29
in ohio he's got a senate race in ohio
he's in the 30s in nevada and georgia
and arizona how's he going to win senate
races when he's doing that badly and his
wayne thing ultra maga backfired they're
printed up t-shirts that say ultra magga
and the country's teetering on a
recession now no good for a smoking job
well you know jessica what do you think
the plan is i mean there are some bright
people in the white house i mean they've
got there's got to be a plan they keep
telling us we have a plan it's no longer
transitory we're going to fix this
things are great tell me how great
things are
no i i don't want to do that but i want
to
try to explain what's going on here no
one goes into an election saying our
campaign strategies say everything is
crappy that's a bad idea no republican
would do that no democrat is going to do
that and there have been a number of
focus groups and these came out right
before the pennsylvania election where
john fetterman wiped the floor with
conor lamb who was the electable
candidate that said democrats want a
fighter and we overwhelmingly believe
that republicans are always ready to go
to the mat and that we seed too much
ground and i think what joe biden is
doing here is to go a bit on the
offensive and to also highlight which a
bunch of his surrogates have been doing
the fact that republicans except for
rick scott's plan which they're running
away from aren't really offering up much
of an alternative and then coupling that
with big social issues that are going on
right now like guns and the leaked
skoda's opinion that there are
democratic voters and independent voters
and even maybe some moderate republican
voters that can be animated by these
issues where frankly republicans are
completely out of step with the american
zeitgeist what's the white house plan to
bring down gas prices
to bring down gas well it wasn't about
gas prices this was his inflation plan
and he was talking about it
well
it's he has i think he has a gas plan
which was that he did authorize more
drilling but he has he released really
gas from the petroleum reserve and the
gas prices went up
right
that was the plan yeah he released more
he said they could do more drilling and
then he pulled back on it i don't think
that that's right i didn't go pack to
increase production and they said screw
you yeah all right everything's crappy
everyone vote republican
right
isn't it important that a president at
least feel the pain that the american
people are feeling uh you know jessica's
saying he can't say everything's crappy
at least he can empathize isn't that
supposed to be his strong people feel
the pain he would be a pure uh what do
you call me masochist because he's
creating the pain
uh you know it's funny it's like he says
he wants to speak for himself but that
seems like that's been the problem since
the beginning he creates a word salad
that would give you e coli
you know the thing is people are
animated by issues like abortion and
guns
but everyone is animated by inflation
because there are some people that
abortion will never enter their lives
right and but inflation hits them
wherever they are and that i think
that's the that's the issue if you don't
have a solution for that i'm looking at
like i believe that the democrats have
given up they're like they're like
behind five touchdowns and they're
choosing to run out the clock because
clearly there's no political road back
here for joe there's no comeback so
rather than even help a little they're
just leaving the field i get that says
sports analogy it was a sports analogy
and i'm not even sure it made any sense
to me because frankly it was a long
weekend and i'm working on about ten
percent of my brain
i didn't get permission to do the
analogy i don't i come up with the
analogies i don't ask for
permission yes yes are you done not
really up next criminals are spending a
long holiday weekend by causing anarchy
in democrat-run cities
i went to brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe
right now